so my favorite exercise in the gym for
building size and strength is drumroll
the drop set sounds pretty simple
straightforward you might be thinking
this is going to be a short and
pointless video but I'm gonna talk a
little bit about how I sometimes do a
drop set slightly differently I'm gonna
talk about why I think it's a useful and
I'm gonna go into a little bit of how it
affects the muscle fibers I believe in a
slightly different way to help you build
both size and strength at once so hang
on to your hats for a rollercoaster ride
of me talking about drop sets
okay so a good place to start what is a
drop set for those of you who do not
know the idea behind drop set is that
you do as many repetitions as you can of
a set exercise on a certain weight and
then when you can do no more when you've
reached failure you immediately drop the
weight down and you carry on so say I
done as many of these as I possibly
could and I was at the point of failure
because that is obviously the definition
of failure
okay he means I would then put these
down take off the weights on the end and
then carry on and do a few more sets
this is any tried and tested technique
it's one that lots of body builders used
and if you want to get creative with it
or if you want to take it to the next
level you do what's called running the
rack here you stand the heaviest end of
the dumbbell wrap you do your curls and
then you move down so you start with
your twenty five moves to 20 move to
fifteen moves to ten all the way down
until you reach the end that's a great
way of really getting a burn on you do
these massive sets there's no rest in
between you're pushing yourself past
failure you're increasing intensity and
everyone in the gym hates you because
your massive dicks you've taken up the
entire dumbbell rack and pretty much
every weight in the play there's a
variation on the drop set that I really
like and that's the mechanical drop set
in the mechanical drop set instead of
changing the weight you change the
exercise still with the same objective
of making it easier so you can do more
repetitions in you normally would and
push past failure dust increasing
intensity and volume at the same time so
in this case let's go back to our
dumbbells we're doing some curls get to
the point we can do no more see it from
that angle again at the point where you
can do no more
and then so instead of dropping the
weight you're just gonna switch and the
mechanism in this case I'm doing a
hammer curl because I find a hammer curl
slightly easier than a bicep curl and
then what you might do is maybe a cheat
hammer curl once you can do many more
tricks hammer curls we're swinging
yourself into the motion because you're
not changing the weight you're changing
the
Paul Newman yeah other know that an
example of this might be to do press
upstairs means you can then drop down
onto your knees and continue doing press
ups or you might do then you put ups as
you can and then start doing assisted
push or you might be stubborn plus with
your legs on the ground called inverted
press ups point is you're pushing
yourself past failure it's very useful
for bodyweight exercises actually and if
you're doing bodyweight training you
should definitely be using the carpet
offsets as one of the only ways you can
make those exercise difficult enough for
you so those are drop sets and those
have a can of a drop sets and you should
be like I say using them at some point
in your exercise I like to use drop set
some cameras drop sets and similar
intensity techniques such as force reps
where you get spotter to help you such
as super sets I do use something like
this but pretty much every exercise I do
so I don't just go in and do curls I'll
do overhand curls quickly switched it
and dumbbell curls switched it hammer
curls or I'll do seated curls to isolate
movement and stand up and carry on then
I might brunch fit in do pull-ups and
what i'm doing here is i'm just really
nuking the biceps and from my experience
that's one of the only ways to get that
real massive feeling of pub quickly
every single time that leads to you
actually progressing if you're just
doing 10 like that reaching failure and
stopping then really you're not going to
grow not gonna see those benefits you
need to feel the intensity as you're
training and that's a great way of doing
that really if those extra three that
you squeeze out once you can do no more
that make you go the rest is just
getting there that doesn't even matter
those 10 before that that doesn't matter
and there's another reason though that I
think drop sets belong in pretty much
all of your exercise and that is that
you can use it as a way to build both
strength and size and this is something
I don't hear people speak about that
often with regards to drop sets so
normally to build strength you would
either lift a very heavy weight for
about three reps two or even one so that
you can do no more that's your one rep
max or you would use overcoming
isometric
which is where you push against a force
he can't move like Bruce Lee I've talked
about before we're trying to curl a bar
that's attached and four by chains
people who try and bend iron bars that's
a form of overcoming isometrics and that
is having you increase your pure
strength you can be thin and still this
will help me build strength because it
increases the connection between your
brain and your muscle fibers thus you
get greater muscle fiber recruitment
when you try and exert strength you've
trained yourself to be able to get those
muscles to really work because you're
pushing yourself at maximum capacity
when you lift it 70 percent all the time
which you need to if you're doing 12 to
15 reps you never get to that point
where you need to really squeeze out all
that strength in your muscles you never
teach your central nervous system to be
able to do that at the same time though
just doing one or two reps that is not
enough to stimulate growth to stimulate
growth meet volume need to increase your
time and the tension again talk about
this before you need to spend longer in
the movement and in the portion of the
movement that really makes you work so
you're not resting your arms in between
the wrong you knew that the more you're
gonna flood your muscles and swell them
up with blood and with oxygen and lactic
acid and you're gonna create more micro
tears and that's how you build size
that's what leads to hypertrophy winning
then sleep and when you feed yourself
with the protein that you need in order
to grow normally people will train one
or the other they say you can't chase
two rabbits unless you can split
yourself into two like the reflectors
from transformers you're probably not a
transformer so you can treat yourself as
a team and you're gonna have to choose
one or the other or so they thought
because if you're using drop sets what
you're really doing is you're going
you're training for strength and then
you can immediately afterwards train for
volume and size so you can go straight
for them trying to lift something
they're very heavy and immediately move
on to moving something that's lighter
but for more repetitions normally drop
set and do something like 12 reps and
then you'll be maybe three more that's
not how I like to do it sometimes I like
to do three reps five reps on something
really heavy and then
down and then do 12 and then gonna do
somethin else entirely into five and
then that's my supermassive thing so
it's been ages and the tension but at
the same time I still had that
opportunity to really test my muscle
fiber recruitment and to really create
strength so you can use drop sets to do
both when I was younger I used to call
this time division and I used to also
throw in isometrics so holding so I
would do maybe my three to five reps on
really heavy so I'm really building the
strength drop it down drop it down drop
it down so I'm really feeling that burn
now cuz I'm doing the volume and then
just hold it there for the end and if
you're a real sadist you can end on
burns which is where you just try and
squeeze them out face to deal with this
just because I could feel that it was
creating the young the good kind of
stimulus and my muscles I was I've
become familiar with what that feels
like it's gonna trigger growth but then
the more I've thought about it and the
more I read about it more I realize that
doing this actually trains
different abilities endurance and
strength size and muscle recruitment and
if you can do all those things at the
same time then you can build yourself a
statically and get bigger and stronger
at the same time as well as increasing
endurance explosive power and anything
say drop set seems pretty simple right
and it's not that exciting like I say
but use them because I think they are
perhaps the best a technique you can use
for increasing intensity and getting
diverse results in the gym that there is
sorry let's say do every exercise with
another exercise and another exercise
and drop the weight don't just do a
weight in isolation that's my favorite
technique in the gym hope you find it
useful and thanks very much for watching
so it's been a while since my last video
by the way I've been very busy a and B I
didn't have to follow up that last video
I did with all the special effects and
the editing of the music you know that
was a tough act to follow so I went just
back to basics with this one in future
as always I'll be talking about
technology
as well as training as well as
nootropics as well as transhumanism and
all the usual stuff on how to be more
like a superhero say if you want to see
any of that please comment and subscribe
to like and I'll see you in the next one
thanks for watching
can your training